مرات عديدة عندما كان هناك
عنف رهيب رهيبة تحدثت عنه أطرافك ،
أريد فقط أن أعرف ما إذا كنت
منخرطًا في أي نوع من الجهد بين
سلطتك والإسرائيليين لتهدئة
التوترات والعنف الحاليين
كانت الولايات المتحدة تلعب
دورًا مهمًا في جلب  الأمور
معًا وكما قلت إن الأمر كله في
أيدي الإسرائيليين ، فإن الإسرائيليين
هم الذين يمليون اللقطات ،
ويمكن للإسرائيليين أن يجعلوا حالة
التصعيد ويمكن للإسرائيليين أن يجعلوا
الوضع هادئًا كل ما رأيناه من
عمليات التوغل وعلى  المسجد ومخيمات
اللاجئين. هدم المنازل القاتلة
ومصادرة الأراضي هذا هو
السبب قبل وقوع الكارثة ، فهذه
وصفة للعنف عندما يكون لديك
وزراء يدعون إلى القضاء على
بلدة حوارة بأكملها عندما يكون لديك وزراء
يدعون كل إسرائيلي إلى حمل السلاح
وإطلاق النار.  كلما دعت الحاجة وما إلى
ذلك ، قامت هذه الحكومة الإسرائيلية
بتغيير قواعد الاشتباك لجعل
القتل أسهل ولتسهيل
كل شيء على الإسرائيليين الذين يحاولون
تهدئة الوضع قدر الإمكان
ولكن كما قلت ، الفلسطينيون تحت
الاحتلال نحن  هم ضحايا وكل شيء
في أيدي الإسرائيليين هم الذين
يمليون الطلقات وهم من
يتخذون القرارات وهم
من يستطيعون
تهدئة الوضع وهم
المسؤولون عن أي و  كل تصعيد